Speaker 1: I am going to play for you today
one of the most pathetic Donald Trump videos
that I have ever seen of Donald Trump begging
for money, mentioning one of these completely
imaginary fundraising deadlines that are of
no meaning or value whatsoever. This guy is
desperate. This guy is desperate and it's
pathetic. Listen to Trump's voice here.
Speaker 2: We have a major
fundraising deadline coming up.
Speaker 1: No, you don't. No, you do. This
is the biggest. We have a deadline. It's a
self-imposed deadline. We've got to get
5000 new donors by midnight tonight. No,
you don't. You're just desperate, dude.
Speaker 2: And there's never been a time like
this. Our country has never been so disrespected.
Our country has never been so low, certainly in
the minds of others, and especially the leaders
of other countries all over the world. Yeah,
we have to change it. We have to bring
our country back. We made it, remember?
Speaker 1: Opinion of the United States around
the world has dramatically improved since Donald
Trump left office. Every single poll proves that.
Speaker 2: America is great and now we're going
to have to make America great again. Yeah. So
I say whatever you can do to help out, we have
to meet the deadline. The midterms are coming
up. It's going to be one of the most important
elections in the history of our country.
Speaker 1: That's true only because
of the effect that may have on 2024.
Speaker 2: So I hope you can help up and help
out. We really appreciate it and good luck. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Can I translate this video clip for
you? This message? Here's the translation. I
might actually have to pay my lawyers this time.
Okay. That's the real message that Donald Trump
is espousing here. And look at how disastrously
humiliating fundraising has been. This is an
article on Yahoo! News from the Independent.
Trump's superPAC raised just $40 in August. Okay,
that's not a typo. That's not 40 million. It's
not 4 million. It's not 400,000. Okay. Trump Super
PAC raised $40 in August. Former President Donald
Trump super PAC raised only $40 in the month of
August. In a sign that his name doesn't have the
fundraising pull that it once did, along with the
low August numbers, the Make America Great Again
Again Super PAC only raised $351,000 in July.
Nothing in June. By comparison, in the final
fundraising quarter of last year, the very same
super PAC raised between four and $5 million.
Even in April and May, it raised $864 million
among some of the merchandise that is being
made available. Ah, Jared Kushner's memoir. Trump
wine glasses and a rally speech signed by Trump,
as well as the opportunity to get your name
engraved on a donor wall. Now, as I mentioned,
this is really about legal fees. And the article
says the numbers come as Save America PAC fits
the bill for Trump's legal fees. Last month, it
spent $3.8 million on legal fees, the most spent
on such fees. The entire 22, 20, 22 cycle with
$3 million going to Clinton, Laurier and Coleman,
which is a law firm based in West Palm Beach,
Florida. Remember, MAGA means making attorneys get
attorneys. And MAGA also is extremely lucrative
for lawyers. That's for damn sure. As you know,
Trump is going to have legal fees because of the
Letitia James criminal referral and lawsuit. And
we've got what's happening in Georgia and we've
got the Florida situation with the Mar a Lago
raid. This guy is going to have legal fees up
the wazoo. So when Trump shows up and he's in
his informal wear, right? No, no, no necktie and
says, we've got to meet this fundraising deadline,
what he means is, I might have to pay my lawyers,
I might have to pay my lawyers. It is pathetic
and it is humiliating. He raised $40, guys.
$40. Let's hope that he raises even less.